[Applaudissements]
je ne me sens absolument alors n'est que
l'avant vite parce qu'il ya quand même
s'il y un la bolognaise aujourd'hui
cyril j'aimerais ont forcé une porte que
j'ai entrouvert tiers celle des années
mitterrand
une époque où la liberté d'expression se
développer aussi vite que le chômage et
j'aimerais aujourd'hui qu'on s'attarde
sur l'héritage de mitterrand il a été
élu
élu il ya plus de 40 ans qu'est ce qui
reste de lui aujourd'hui il y à 40 ans
il y avait des débats sur l'abolition de
la peine de mort avec robert badinter
c'est ce monsieur regardez bien les
jeunes il n'a pas fait de télé réalité
il disait demain la justice française ne
sera plus une justice qui tutoie
punchline de rappeur booba tiens toi
tranquille et quarante ans après nous
avons le successeur de robert badinter
gilles verdez on parle de koh lanta
l'ultime sylla fallait que c'est
scénarisé
pourquoi c'est pas forcément dans
l'épisode pendant l'épisode au moment du
tournage nomme et les gens de la
production qui sont là bas ils ont vu
deux choses les armes secrètes ça ne
servait à rien le bracelet noir on
l'utilisait pas et vincent surclassé
tout le monde
donc ils se sont dit on va à cette
émission là en profiter tant pis on
prend le risque consorts vincent et on
truque aucun ne se sont dit qu'ils
allaient surclassé tout le monde que ça
n'avait plus d'intérêt
ils ont préféré garder thomas le paul
négatif c'est bien la voir amiens voilà
quand je vois ça j'ai l'impression de
revoir le discours de badinter à
l'assemblée nationale pour l'abolition
de la peine de mort d'ailleurs milk sont
les deux aient regardé à peine de mort
est contraire à ce que l'humanité depuis
2000 ans à penser de plus haut elle est
contraire à la foi à l'esprit du
christianisme et à l'esprit de la
révolution a marre pu faire à moi bon
temps ce trouble est un jeune homme qui
s'appelait patrick henry croyez moi à ma
stupéfaction quand je l'aï appris j'ai
compris ce que ce jour-là pouvait
signifier la valeur dissuasive de la
peine de mort
[Applaudissements]
cette drogue surtout c'est la tête de
monaco n'en sait pas parler de lui il ya
40 ans il y avait aussi une association
qui s'appelait l'arc est qui luttait
contre le cancer quarante ans après hier
on a eu aussi un arc sur ce plateau mais
pas celui contre le cancer
bah oui ça m'a rappelé mon bon alors
c'est l'arc là quand tu tires et que tu
dois éliminés qu'ils ne savent pas c'est
bien quand même pas eu d'accord lors
comment comment ça s'est passé en fait
tu vas tu arrives à faire passer ça la
douane parce que c'est compliqué de le
mettre au fond de ce clip n'est pas sa
place il part ce nom serait était parti
avec moi mais comment tu l'as mis dans
ce match comme un singe nommé dans la
valise s'est passé alors j'adore mon mot
qui a un être formidable mais c'est un
mytho managériales tous les koh-lanta
avec lui j'ai jamais vu tirer à l'arc
même par contrat soir je les ai vus
menacés tout le monde avec une machette
et ça a fait monter le front national de
10% comme mitterrand d'ailleurs il ya 40
ans faisait des concerts pour aider
l'afrique avec des morceaux comme we are
the world cyril aujourd'hui on fait des
concerts pour que les gens aillent se
faire vacciner avec des invités qui
n'ont rien à voir les uns avec les
autres
le prince harry selena gomez est le pape
on dirait un plateau de thé pmp
[Applaudissements]
mitterrand j'espère qu'ils seront sur la
dernière a donné qu'ils vieillissent on
les a lancés pour finir françois
mitterrand c'est un héritage social et
politique pour l'évoquer j'ai décidé de
vous replonger dans le passé et vous
faire partager ce reportage qui date
d'il ya 40 ans 3 2 1 françois mitterrand
est élu président de la république par
faith rochois quartier cosmopolite du
nord de paris
embaumé par les senteurs de safran de
muscade et d'huile d'olive au lendemain
de l'élection de françois mitterrand
nous sommes allés à la rencontre de ses
habitants d'origine exotique pour savoir
comment ils réagissent à l'élection du
premier président de gauche de la vème
république
bonjour monsieur points wii a qoui poesy
bonjour alors dites-nous qu'est ce que
vous pensez de la victoire de françois
mitterrand
ah ben moi je suis bien content puisque
c'est la première fois je vote et je
suis vraiment ému parce que c'est une
victoire de la gauche où il voit là et
vétérans c'est quelqu'un qui va tenir
parole donc fini des emplois précaires
fils racisme nous a dit s'engager à sa
fille nie tout ce qui est bavure
policière parce qu'on a entendu plein de
copains du temps et voilà et moi en vous
faire une amère il habitait dans un
bidonville inventaire coucou dentaire et
donc je suis vachement content
d'ailleurs j'ai un pote à moi là c'est
le choix je peux vous présenter c'est
mon pote ki vien d'espagne s'est fait un
nom et naturalisé comoedia main à
l'armée avant manuel vals gr son père
centre est mal de français et je pense
qu'avec mitterrand il va prendre
confiance il va faire des trucs pour le
pays voilà c'est rare
la intervilles merci souhaitons à ce jeu
de base années que l'histoire lui donne
raison
et oui il ya toujours la fin des
émissions sur le tard la tenue qui a
voté mitterrand aussi le premier vote
oui mais c'est en 80 bêtes et c'était
mon premier match et dès mon premier
match et quel est votre premier 74
n'avait pas l'âge de voter nous y
regarder voilà vous voyez un petit peu
l'ambiance krtb savoir 20 80 j'ai voté
blanc
d'accord on s'en fout totalement
moralité le plus grand talent de
françois mitterrand c'était de nous
faire croire pendant deux ans qu'il
était de gauche